لنا الادعاء العام في السويد انا تحقيقه
في التفجيرات التي تعرض لها خطان نوت
ستريم 1.2 قاد الى العثور على مواد ناسفه
واجسام غريبه بالقرب منهما وفيما اكد
لدعاء السويدي ان العمل التحليليه المتطور
مستمر لكشف المزيد من الاستنتاجات القاطعه
رحب الكريملين بتاكيد السويد فرضيه حدوث
هجوم ارهابي مشددا على ضروره تحديد من يقف
وراءه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاث وسرق ما هي الابعاد القانونيه
والامنيه والسياسيه لتاكيد التحقيق الدولي
وقوف عمل تخريبيا ارهابيا وراء تفجير خطين
واحد واثنين وكيف ترى موسكو هذا المنحه
الذي اخذه التحقيق الدولي بما قد ينجر عنه
من تبعات القانونيه وسياسيه وكيف ستتصرف
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها الاوروبيون مع
ما سيتوصل اليه التحقيق من نتائج نهائيه
واخيرا اي اهداف محتمله مستقبلا لاعمال
تخريبيه مماثله وهي تاثير سيكون لذلك على
مسار الحرب التي تشنها روسيا على اوكرانيا
وما يقف وراءها من الصفافات الدوليه
[موسيقى]
جديده في التحقيقات بشان التفجيرات التي
تعرض لها
واحد واثنان تشير الى عمل تخريب وادله على
عمل ارهابي يقف وراء محدث
الغربيه لاتهامها على اي حال
المدعي العام السويدي ماكس قائد وفريق
التحقيقات وصف التحقيقات بانه
معقده او بانها معقده
الى ان نتائج التحقيقات المستمره ستؤكد
امكانيه تقديم اي شخص للاشتباه في ارتكاب
جريمه وكان تفجيرالحق اضرار
واحد واثنين في بحر البلطيق وتبادل روسيا
ودول الغربيه الاتهامات في ذلك الوقت
في موسكو قال المتحدث باسم الرئاسه
الروسيه ديميتري ديسكو ان بلاده ترحب
بتاكيد السويد فرضيه الهجوم الارهابيه على
خطوط انابيب غاز نور
هذا يؤكد مره اخرى المعلومات التي تملكها
روسيا مشددا على ضروره تحديد الجهه التي
تقف وراء هذا الانفجار
[موسيقى]
والمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من مصر
خبير في الصندوق الوطني الروسي لامن
الطاقه من واشنطن الدكتور بن جميل الخبير
في سياسات الامن والدفاع في معهد
الدكتور حسني عبيدي استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه جنيف اهلا بكم جميعا
ونبدا مع الدكتور فريدمان من واشنطن اذن
تحقيق جديد ما اهميته
وابوي
النتائج التي يبدو انها مهمه جدا نحن لا
نعرف من
فجر خط غاز الشمال هنا في واشنط نقول انها
روسيا ولكن ليس هناك ادله كافيه على ذلك
الى حد الان ربما قامت بذلك بعض البلدان
في اوروبا او حتى الولايات المتحده ربما
او بعلم الولايات المتحده على الاقل
تكتشف ان احد اكبر
خلفائها في اوروبا
والرياضه النساء
معقد سياسيا
ربما ايضا
في هذا التقرير انه يتحدث عن جهه
التخريبيه ارهابيه تقف وراءها هو الامر
الذي ذهبت اليه موسكو من البدايه
ما تعليقكم على ما توصلت اليه خصوصا انا
موسكو راحبت هذه المره بالنتائج التحقيق
راسي سكوتر
المصلحه من هذه العمليات الارهابيه في
خطوط الغاز واحد واثنين المصلحه للولايات
المتحده وليس من المهمه من قام بهذا هو
ايدي من التي قامت بهذا بولندا او
بريطانيا او الولايات المتحده المهم ان في
النتيجه
في العقوبات ضد روسيا او كانوا ينضموا
لدعم
اوكرانيا عسكريا وتقديم الاسلحه كانوا
ينظر الى الوراء هو يتفكر وكيف سوف يؤثر
هذا عن العلاقات الروسيه الاوروبيه اما
الان بعد همم ما وقفت بالغاز عن الضخم
وتدمرت المانيا لا تنظر لهذا وتقوم بجراه
بفرض القيود على روسيا وهذا الهدف الاساسي
من العمليه الارهابيه في النوت ستريم ليس
لروسيا اي هدف من تفجير انابيبها للغاز
خاصه انه لم يكن هناك اي دخل للغاز اثناء
فتره التفجير هذا هذه كانت عمليه رمزيه
تقوم بها
الولايات المتحده حتى تقوم بتصدير الغاز
السائل لاوروبا وهي الاولى في تصدير الغاز
السائل لاوروبا اوروبا
تم اليوم دكتور حسني عبيدي والسؤال هو عن
الابعاد السياسيه والقانونيه لما تم
الاعلان عنه
وتساؤل هناك مسافه بين الرؤيا الغربيه
الاوروبيه وال متحده ام تم بالتنسيق
بينهما
المؤكد ان همم
السويدي يعني خطط خطوه ايجابيه ومهمه جدا
مقارنه مع دول اوروبيه اخرى يعني اولا
لانها حددت قبل كل شيء مدعي عام
بالاهتمام بهذه القضيه ثم انك ما تعلمين
مسرح الجريمه وتحت الماء وبالتالي تتطلب
جهد كبير جهد قانونيا لان جزء من العمليه
وقع في المياه الاقليميه ما يسمى بالمنطقه
الاقتصاديه والجزء في المياه الدوليه لا
يخص السويد ثم النقطه الاخرى تقدم هو ان
هناك قناع كامل قانوني بان العمليه هي
عمليه مدبره وعمل تخريبي وهناك جهه اجنبيه
وهو التعبير القانوني للاجسام الغريبه هل
هي مثلا هل هي غواصه او هل هو هل هي مثلا
طائره مسيره او ربما عسكريين هذه نقطه
اخرى لم يصل اليها التحقيق وهو تحديد
الاشخاص او تحديدا الجهه تحديد المسؤوليات
هذه القضاء اعتقد تحقيق وايدي في النهايه
قبل كل شيء سيؤدي بالدنمارك في الاسراء
بتحقيقه لان الدنمارك كذلك معنا بهذه
القضيه ثم كذلك سيخص الحلف الاطلسي
والسويد تحذر نفسها للالتحاق بهذا واعتقد
ان الموقف السويدي سيكون موقف مراقب جدا
من قبل الحلف الاطلسي مهما كانت نتائجه في
ستكون لديها ارتدادات داخل الدول
الاوروبيه وكذلك الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه همم سيد همم
طبعا همم السويد معنيه اكثر من اي طرف اخر
موسكو كانت تقول ان الاستخبارات
البريطانيه هي تحديدا من يقف وتقول ان اي
تحقيق تقوم بهذه الدول فانه سيؤدي الى نوع
من الاتهام لروسيا انها ستستغل التحقيق
للالتهاب روسيا الان وقد جاءت النتيجه
التحقيق على ما جاءت عليه
مو اسكت يرحب من جديد هذا الترحيب هلا هو
دلاله هنا
الان كونه عمل متعمد تخريبي
باستخدام قنابل هذا الشيء اصبع كان معروف
في اول ساعات بعد الحادث لانه
تفجرت ثلاث خطوط
عن طريق الصدفه
كان في القاع لعشر سنوات ولم يكن هناك اي
حوادث وهنا تتفجر
يتفجر خطين ثم الخط الثالث لذلك روسيا لا
ترى اي شيء جديد في الاعلام
امكانيه للوصول الى مكان التفجير لان
الانابيب في المياه الدنماركيه لم تكن
مدمره لم يسقط الضغط في هذه الانابيب
وبالنسبه للجستروم كان من المهم ان نعلم
هل ممكن ان نستمر في استخدام هذه الانابيب
ام لا لضخ الغاز في هذه الشتاء اذا اراد
هذا الاوربيون لذلك يجب ان نفهم هل هي
مدمره ام لا وهل ممكن استخدامها ام لا
لذلك هذا الشيء بالنسبه لانه هو الشيء
الاهم ان الدنمارك تسمح للجسترومان تفتش
على الانابيب لذلك استمرار همم
تحقيقات ليست شيء الاهم لانه ليس هناك
لجنه مشتركه بين الدنماركوا المانيا
وبريطانيا
اعتقد ان هناك اهداف مختلفه من هذه
اسقاط اذا كانوا يرفضون التعاون فيما
بينهم
هل في هذه التحقيقات التي تم الاعلان عنها
ما قد يؤدي الى ربما تعاون جديد ضيفنا من
موسكو يقول ليس هناك اي تعاون بين هذه
الدول هل يعني هذا ان ما تم الكشف عنه
ربما يحتاج الى مسار امامي ومن ثم نتوقع
حجم اكبر
وتسليط الضوء اكبر على ما جرى
بعد قطري وهو ان المدعي العام حرك تحقيق
قضائي نظرا لان المياه همم المياه المنطقه
الاقتصاديه تعرضت الى عمل تخريبي لكن
رسميا لم يتم استدعاء دول اخرى للمشاركه
هناك رغبه من قبل العديد من الدول
الاوروبيه ان تشارك لكن في الى حد اللحظه
هذا
المدعي التحقيق قامت به فقط لاجهزه
الامنيه السويديه هي تتعاون مع الدنمارك
لكن لم تدعى اي دوله اخرى لهذه
العمل القضائي المرحله المتقدمه عندما تصل
السويد الى نتائج مهمه فانها يمكن في
النهايه ان تعطي بعد دولي اما باشراك
الدول المطله على البطيخ وهو كما كما ترى
ذلك هو الدول المتضرره لكن جاسترو انه
يسمى بمجمع جهاز بروم الذي لديه هيئه
قانونيه وهو وهو الهيئه التي تسير ااا
نصره وعدوا واثنان لديه كذلك الحق في رفع
الدعوه قضائيه وفي تحريك ذو المطالبه
باجراء تحقيق كما فسامح حتى هو بعض الدول
بالدخول في المياه الاقليميه ومعاينه
الاضرار
في الواقع ربما اسمحوا لي فقط ان اتوقف
عندما اعلنه الادعاء العام السويدي والذي
اثار ردود فعل بينها ما صرح همم به
المتحدث باسم الحكومه الالمانيه تحديدا
قال انه همم ما تم الكشف عنه يعزز روايه
برلين بان التفجير كان متعمدا لانه متابع
مقاله
سمعني اكتب زومبي
ان تفجير نوت ستريم عمل تقريبيه وهو ما
توصلت اليه الفحوص السويديه او اكدت الان
لكن ليس هناك الكثير مما يمكن قوله عن هذا
لانه ليس لدي اي معلومات اخرى وهذا يتعلق
بحقيقته انه عثر على بقايا المتفجرات
بالفعل
في النهايه ربما كان هناك اتفاق من
البدايه ان هناك شيء من يعني ايادي تقف
وراء هذا التفجير
وقالتها روسيا وقالتها الولايات المتحده
وقال لها الاوروبيون ولكن وجهه اصابعهم
لجهات مختلفه الان بعد ما ظهر والطريقه
التي تعاملت بها موسكو مع هذا التحقيق هل
سنلمس لغه جديده من واشنطن بشان الجهه
التي تتتهم فيها
رد على ذلك
المتحده ان كان لهم فكره عن عن من ارتكب
العمل لكن ذلك لا يبدو انه من الصعب ان
يغير لهجتهم وعلى اسود الدين ان يعرفوا
انا اشعر بالمفاجاه من الهدوء الذي
يخيم على السلطات الروسيه
ولو كان
التقرير يشير الى كانوا رد الفعل بقوه
اه ايام سبيك سبينس
[موسيقى]
عندما يتم الكشف عن الجهه التي تقف وراء
ذلك
بقول انه لم يكن جريمه بل كان خطا
والقيام بمثل هذه الاعمال
بعيد عن المستوى الاخلاقي وهو غامض اذا
اعتقد
ان الاوروبيين او الدول الاوروبيه اذا
كانت قامت بذلك
فسيكون ذلك همم خطا تاريخيا
الولايات المتحده هل الولايات المتحده
بمنئه ايضا على الاتهام خصوصا ان يعني
سمعنا ما كانت الالمانيه ممكن تتحدث عنه
من ضغوط امريكيه بشان تشغيل
وايضا في النهايه ربما مصلحه روسيا بعيده
عن هذا العمل التخريبي
حقيقه لا اعرف ولكنها امكانيه
ويمكن ان تكون المتحده قامت بذلك
وربما بعض الجهات الحكوميه عرفت بذلك
مسبقا وانا او ربما البلدان الامريكيه او
كان لها علم مسبق بذلك ايضا لا يدري احد
من الواضح انه يتبين ان الولايات المتحده
للدفاع عن ذلك سيكون هناك جهود من اجل
توصل لهذه التحقيقات الى نتائج
كويس ومن الناحيه السياسيه سيكون بمثابه
انفجار همم واعود لي ضيفنا في موسكو
ايجوريوشكوف يعني في النهايه الروايه
الروسيه عندما بدات وجهت اصابع الاتهام
للاستخبارات البريطانيه هل تتمسك موسكو
بهذه الروايه في هذا الوقت في انتظار
النتائج ام ان ربما التحقيقات ستسد الباب
على هذا المنزلق الخطير
جوالي
بريطانيا
احد المشتركين في هذا العمل التخري
بالارهاب
الموقف الرسمي لموسكو يعتمد على اننا يجب
ان نقوم بالتحقيقات ولكن اذاكر ان الغاز
تم حوله
سامحوا له بالنظر لموقع الحادث بعد شهر من
الحادث وهنا هناك الكثير من الاسئله لماذا
كانوا يحتاجون لكل هذا الوقت حتى يسمح
للقلب همم
هي مصلحه الولايات المتحده
تدمر العلاقات بين اوروبا وروسيا في مجال
الطاقه العلاقات التي كانت تستمر ل 50 سنه
لماذا كما قلتي روسيا اكثر هدوءا في
الحديث عن هذا العمل لان فكره تصدير الغاز
لاوروبا تغيرت بالسابق كانت روسيا تريد ان
توصل الغاز لاوروبا بشكل مباشر للمستخدم
الاخير الان السيد بوتين قال ان ناس سوف
نبقى الغاز على حدود همم على الحدود
الاوروبيه في تركيا سوف ننشئ مركز لتوزيع
الغاز
والاوربين هم عليهم ان يوصلوا الغاز الى
انهم عن طريق حدود بلغاريا وتركيا لذلك
الان هذا شيء غير موضوعي الحديث عنه
مقارنه بالماضي
قد يكون غير موضوعي دكتور من ولكن في
النهايه هناك مشكل مشكله طاقه والسؤال هل
الغرب والولايات المتحده ربما بصدد همم
تبني استراتيجيه جديده ربما يعني او طريقه
جديده في التعامل مع الامر استنتجتها من
هذه التفجيرات وما ادت اليه وما تم الكشف
عنه حتى الان
جديده لهذا التحقيق وهذه القضيه ما نسمعه
من مواجهه هو يكون لا شيء
ويبدو ان استراتيجتنا هي الانتظار اللي
معرفتي ما يجري
مساله الغاز المسال
هي
مساله
كثير من الناس في الولايات المتحده
يريدوننا ان يصدر المزيد من الغاز المسيء
الى اوروبا اعتقد انها ليست فكره
ممتازه المتحده ينظرون اليها بطريقه
مختلفه لو كنا نبيع الغاز المسال اكثر الى
اوروبا سيزيد ذلك سعر الغاز همم
الولايات المتحده
الدكتور
ما تاثير ولو هناك تاثير متبادل بين هذا
الملف همم الملف التفجيرات ومسارات الحرب
الاوكرانيه على المدى المنظور والمدى
البعيد
يعني النقطه الاولى اعتقد ان السويد يعني
تتليف في هذه التحقيقات لان اين نتائج
تؤدي الى تحديد المسؤوليه سواء اوروبيا او
روسيا او امريكيين ستكون لديها نتائج
خطيره على التحالف لان الجديد وعلى الحرب
في اوكرانيا لان النقطه السياسيه حساسه
النقطه الثانيه بالنسبه كذلك لمستقبل له
لتداعيات القانونيه فاعتقد اذا يعني
حسب ما مالات هذا التحقيق فا ربما سيؤدي
كذلك الى التقليد جديد او على الاقل لي
يكون هناك همم تكون هناك عمليه قانونيه
وقضى قضائيه همم بعقوبات جديده تتعلق باي
اعمال عدائيه او اعمال تخريبيه خاصه في
المياه همم الدوليه سواء كان في وقت الحرب
او في وقت السلم لكن كل هذه تقريبا توقعات
التوقع وتتوقف على نتيجه التحقيقات
المرحله الثانيه التي تجرها السويد
اشكرك دكتور من جنيف وشكرا للدكتور بانجي
من فريدمان من واشنطن وبن موسكو ايجور
يشكوف الخبير في الصندوق الوطني الروسي
شكرا جزيلا لكم جميعا وهمم الى هناك تنتهي
هذه الحلقه من برنامج مراد
[موسيقى]